so a doctor shares what happens when men  get height lengthening surgery  which part lengthens we'll get into that  right now  but compare our femurs now let's see  your s what the heck  yeah  oh you're not the same Mobility his  knees just travel forward Steamers he's  got them boots on too though I think she  has average femors  we face that way to do the squad face  I'm just kidding hey hey you know I  don't feel comfortable Put the gun down  I think I'm gonna  all right  bye take your long femurs with you I'm  out of here guys are you ever too secure  about your height that you have so much  of it too soon yeah I'm five twelve  you're tall he's dark  what I always thought I was freakishly  tall oh go [ __ ] yourself you go in the  room and they're like hey guys I'm so  insecure